leur maman anne hidalgo a fait un truc
de ouf
anne hidalgo qui est actuellement la
maire de paris elle va repasser ou par
rachida dati et elle est encore freinée
d'algos à écouter je suis pas paris
comme ça ce sera fait maintenant moi je
le disais tout à l'heure vous avez été
bien gentils parce que bon à la dalle a
parlé des lignes de métro moi je pense
qu'elle avait raison sauf qu'à la marche
et dix minutes pour aller chez tf1 ce
que porte de saint-cloud tf1 il ya 10
minutes de marche avait dû se faire
soigner chez elle à fermer les voies sur
berge c'est chiant parce qu'il ya de la
pollution et j'ai demandé à vos équipes
de retrouver des images dont j'espère
qu'ils ont et efficace mois à l'adie
instauré selon moi at-il ont retrouvé à
bravo aux équipes
elle a dit un truc selon moi qui est
gros mais alors mais c'est en démago on
va le voir et vous donnez nous explique
un peut pas faire on peut pas faire mon
nom là je sais pas du hasard
un geste qui serait l'image mais bravo
aux équipes si l'on trouvait allez-y
mais en lisant bien votre programme sur
le sujet j'ai trouvé cette phrase cette
proposition on va trouver des solutions
pour les professionnels pour passer du
camion au vélo du camion au vélo donc
les déménageurs où les plombiers avec
leur boîte à outils ils vont devoir
apprendre le vélo 1 sur la voiture mais
l'on comprend mais vous savez par
exemple aujourd'hui beaucoup de
professionnels à paris utilise par
exemple des vélos cargo je pense à des
plombiers je pense à beaucoup de
personnes
et vous savez je crois qu'il faut
vraiment regarder le monde qui vient le
préparer ne pas regarder dans le
rétroviseur
[Rires]
la demande des ménages d'ordinateurs dès
l'année prochaine les photos des ménages
féraud mais von arx des centres qui font
les marchés les mecs moi tous les jours
sur mon camion et entre 5 et 7 tonnes de
chargement mais je les mets tous les
symptômes sont en vélo la surface des
allers-retours la quinqua gel sinndar
caf un déménagement vélo qui avait dans
l'air les noms mais à mon avis tu sais
quoi les plombiers vélo les plombiers
les chauffeurs livreurs les pompes
doivent être non hélas cette année c'est
au tour de france car son coma
[Applaudissements]
il va préparer une recette au cas où
vélo karim ben mccalman actif vélo cargo
donc tous les gens si vous voulez des
livraisons mais non bord de l'eau ne
boire de l'eau vous livrera au bordeaux
lens et nan tu es gentil mais c'est vrai
nom man is a good day quelque chose a
dit nago sont ma vie c'est
extraordinaire
anne hidalgo on n'a rien contre toi ma
chérie non c'est moi ç'aurait voies sur
berge fermé non mais quelle voir sur
badge faire tu dois t'on maintenant tu
vas délivré en vélo frère je vais
l'aimer tous est tard tu vas voir mes
mollets mon frère ça va être
et quand tu des ménages de nice à paris
sur l'autoroute avec deux frigos dans sa
il a raison c'est beaucoup mieux que le
métro mais je suis d'accord avec ça
c'est extraordinaire sérielle se démonte
pas la bafin à l'argument ya david
pujadas et lui dit les plombiers les
trucs donneront beaucoup tu que tu
racontes mec t'as jamais fait 50 avec
une charge de tout
ah ça non mais son ego et s il y avait
en tout cas les parisiens où ça va quand
le maner connaître bientôt frères tous
ceux qui m'ont gardée du major dans le
sud l'été parisien
c'est pas possible de dire des conneries
sans déconner mais moi je t'explique je
leur passer tous les jours
bravo moratoire est bon
[Applaudissements]